it is becoming a familiar sight
roads turn to car parks
the traffic heading out of the uk is
relentless
as the port of dover and the euro tunnel
faced one of their busiest days ever
frustration mounted amidst the tens of
thousands of vehicles that tried to pass
through
nothing's moving for six hours
the anxiety and the stress levels and
then you get sort of you know
people get angry so how long have you
been in your car for about five hours
now and how long has your journey meant
to be 15 minutes it's the people who've
been working hard and they want to go on
their holidays enjoy themselves and it
starts off chaos flights have been
delayed all cancelled so flying wasn't a
good option either i don't think there's
any good option to get away this summer
and tonight the question remains who is
to blame for this ongoing chaos the fact
is that the french authorities have not
put enough people on the border and i'm
in touch with the french authorities i'm
very clear that we need to see action
from them to resolve the terrible
situation that people are facing
so not brexit's fault says the foreign
secretary bidding for the top job
instead it's the guys on the other side
of the channel what do you want us to do
do you want us if we have 100 of the
capacities allowed by the british port
authorities in dover to the french
police
do you want us not to have controls not
to check passports not to check cars i
thought that brexit was about taking
back control nothing to do with us say
the french whilst pointing the finger at
britain's infrastructure
we knew it was going to be busy we
invested in new infrastructure we've
trained up additional people to operate
in in the lanes and so we were ready all
we need is for resources to be deployed
according to that plan
perhaps really it's just a perfect storm
we've witnessed the carnage at airports
over the last few weeks as people have
tried to get away it's now being
replicated
on the roads this queue for the euro
tunnel stretches back for miles but this
is really the first test since leaving
the eu and resurfacing from a pandemic
and clearly it's not going that well
the concern is this scale of disruption
could now be the new norm our big summer
getaways hampered by the effects of
brexit and a lack of resource
throwing many holidays into question
insurance rasheed sky news in kent